yeah i don't know there's like i think
it's like again with made cultures right
we
we don't like it when people are fake to
us
yeah and when we know they're being fake
to us yeah yeah and
i guess that's why youtubers and live
streamers have done well so long because
it's it's
poised as this real thing right yeah
yeah it's not such a character yeah it's
just a genuine thing
you know and there are some people out
there who are and there are some people
out there who most definitely aren't no
no we've seen both sides which is why
like i never understood like real
japanese idol culture
in in japan because the one thing i
didn't understand was this idea that
these real human beings needed to be
perfect that is that is the japanese
character if they're anything but
perfect they get [ __ ] destroyed they
need to be pure
yeah i was pure that you want to
because because it's it's when you you
are in
imbuing fictional aspects to real people
and you expect real people to act
like fictional characters the reason
waifu's work is because they can be
perfect or they it's the idea of them
that is perfect i remember one
uh [ __ ] great japanese meme that came
out of idols this is
years ago like this started on 2chan but
there was a thread
of uh of some some person [ __ ]
critiquing
idols and idol culture that kind of [ __ ]
and there was this one reply of this
like
absolute sim for idols who was like oh
idols don't poop
they don't poop
all gets converted into because that's
the perfect human being yeah it all gets
converted to energy yeah
and then that turned into a meme where
it's like if something is so pure
they're just like yeah they don't poop
yeah they don't poop i just don't poop
they're perfect in every sense i mean
they [ __ ] rainbows yeah they [ __ ]
rainbows i'll eat their [ __ ] why not
it's like a lion
already clowning it's like microsoft
i don't know it's oh my god it's hard
because
there's so many i guess because
youtubers have gotten in that perfect
spot
where it's like it it has done the
everything right that kind of goes
against the rules of other things that
would make it uncomfortable
i mean it's it's i find it [ __ ]
amazing how just how
quickly vg was have exploded because i
remember
when keys and i debuted like she she
started
a massive [ __ ] wave of japanese
youtubers yeah and
nobody here gave a [ __ ] at all right
yeah there's some people who like kiznai
but i think
i feel like he was kids in the eye and
like there was like a top three i think
yeah it was kaguya and like shiro yeah i
think with the top three yeah that were
like the most
had the most attention and then there
was like a bt of like
a lot of like kind of smaller like 100k
and then the
the ct was like actual thousands tens of
thousands tens of thousands
and i but like i feel like we're just on
the cusp of like something
similar happening to the
english-speaking culture i'm excited
because it's fun because i feel like it
could either be
like you said like something giant could
come and it could really establish
itself or it could be a flash in the
past i think it's a little bit different
though than the
the the v tube a youtuber so right
because with the beach of a youtuber
side there was this like
big three or like there was a couple of
really big faces that were kind of
pulling the entire
community but i feel like i think that
will happen though yeah but i feel that
with like the live streamers like with
hall alive and niji sanji
yeah everybody's kind of at the top at
the same time like the
entire community is growing at once it's
not so much one person
leading the way it'll eventually level
out there is